in this section we're going to
concentrate on what we're looking
forward to playing next year 2016 only a
couple of months left so you don't
really have that much in the con for the
rest of 2015 looking forward towards
2016 and a lot of things to get excited
about Justin first of all what were what
were some of the games they jumped out
to you the Sony shot off today it was so
long it was like two hours oh my god it
look all scripts okay this is the list
of games that we have currently that I
have to know get through notice Danny's
using a mouse with his laptop I am
because the trackpad is broken
Bolsheviks shows you know it's great
going into having these experiences that
that don't feel super new but I do like
the mix of old technology and new with
something like horizon zero dawn yeah
like that looked really cool that big
dinosaur battle and we've seen that
before and I feel like we've seen it
from a different standpoint this time
like she was taken down the dinosaur in
a different way yeah that looked really
awesome yeah that's a that's a name of
the game and a cop one of a couple of
stage demos and that we got looks
beautiful as well yeah it reminds me of
what was a third person vanquished sure
reminds me of vanquish is something
especially she has like a little slide
maneuver that she does where is she I
don't know they're gonna show right here
she comes rockets on her ankles no but
she slides on her knees for like way
longer than momentum dictates oh yeah
that was kind of that reminded me of
anguish for sure what I don't understand
is why is she wearing furs but fighting
things that shoot lasers and his fully
armored you know if she's you know
pulling off armor and things from there
would check a lot maybe some plate knob
because like they hate the machines
right cuz the technologies what killed
their forefathers you're like [ __ ]
I'm gonna wear mink instead does it
looks dope and another game and all
about exploring weird and wonderful
worlds and we finally got a release date
for was no land sky it's coming in june
twenty sixty III time yeah excited about
that one Mike yeah but excited for no
mask I for just like a lot of people for
a long time and every time they push it
back or they just kind of a hazy on one
that's gonna release I see no Sean
Murray was tweeting yesterday or
something he's like they were really
sorry that we can't be more specific but
we really don't want to screw this up we
really want to nail it and I agree with
my I just say take your time and bring
it out so we can enjoy when it comes out
and it looks every time I see it just
makes me want to play it more just kind
of that pure exploration without too
much intent kind of like a bethesda game
almost like those kind of sand boxes I'm
still I'm still curious as to whether
Nomad sky will have enough substance to
the exploration to like keep me coming
back yeah but just I got like a purely
that maybe like a week or two of just
exploring sounds awesome so I'm glad
I'll be able to have that like at the
end of the busy spring season and the
voiceovers Rutger car is that his name
forget I don't know a guy from Blade
Runner and also hobo with a shotgun and
if every twenty seventh we got our sorry
for every sixteenth we got a release
date for a street fighter 5 as well
hello doll sims in the game yeah who
would have known and six other
characters which we don't really know
who they are as well that's Eric tell
you figured that out yet there was no it
was out data mining yesterday looks like
thought they found ibuki and jury
character data okay I'm the beta so
maybe let's talk about the way you
unlock these characters though because
it's kind of a by fighting in the street
by using fight money yeah yeah yeah tell
me about fight money uh remember when
used to play fighting games and you beat
arcade mode and it would like unlock a
new character yeah yeah so there it's
sort of like that where you're not using
DLC or anything else you're playing the
game to unlock new characters the set on
the right uh that looks like Dudley Oh
Tommy gun on the last second in from the
left that looks like a boxer yonder
Apollo hahaha sorry fight anyone I money
yeah so for some reason there's an
in-game currency I don't know what why
you need that but that's how you unlock
new characters that's not dlc it's you
know they're essentially avoiding the
folly of what they did with street
fighter cross tekken where they had
characters on the disk and and then they
released it as dlc yeah so to play
devil's advocate do you think they could
implement microtransactions with a fight
money yeah yeah and they are only day
one go there I'm sure they're yeah a
hundred percent that's what I was yeah
but it but if I mean look like that I
think Street Fighter fans will play the
game enough you know the build is sort
of like people who really like Street
Fighter will play it enough and they'll
eventually just unlock enough money sure
I don't think it's the sort of game
where like five hours in you're gonna
thank man i'm bored I need to like get
something new out of this experience
final throw down ten bucks yeah maybe if
you're super curious but I I think this
you know this game will
itself too long play sessions anyway so
yeah I'm personally not too worried
about microtransactions go that's me a
couple of other games mentioned as well
let's see if they take us on these
vector no probably a beachy of him she's
gonna be playing VG yeah sorry and a
matter fall which is the new oh yeah
House warehouse market resogun the best
launch game when Pete ps4 yeah yeah
great this looks very much like CG
trailer for a more indie looking game
though right little bit yeah but that's
it I'll take those shooter maybe is what
its gonna be yeah it's going to be
probably a great action game that people
will love there you go I heard it here
first folks uncharted 4 we saw another
little trailer some of the most similar
players well that trailer was kind of BS
to me let me through that thing in a big
Eldorado that's what I was sarcophagus
from the other fortune yet that was
really cool yeah Leah I'm get me hyped
yeah they're doing all the supernatural
elements but yeah they weren't the idea
but the trailer was showing gameplay
looks like I was from one perspective to
the yes it's like this is not what the
experience is gonna be like you are a
camera flying through a pre-scripted
battle you get to see all the carrier I
was back here I'm solely I'm drinking I
was like writing our news story and I
kept typing gameplay wait a minute there
wasn't gameplay no it's just footage
it's just hyper these humans murdering
each other it's great anyone can be a
little image but a game that actually
works like actually say in real time is
very different yeah shoot that lady
there's something weird about them
wearing like more civilian clothes that
sort of makes fulfill fit more gross
sames ray look at my ease marine he's a
soldier that's good jade is a murder
someone she's wearing gap I guess yeah
exactly hit in the face I'll be
surprised if there was like some sort of
brought to you by banana republic let's
just remind you that Drake is a
homicidal maniac who murders everyone he
needs yeah him and law profs we've got a
real good body count game going on there
and let's move on to the latest fever
dream from Media Molecule ad actually
earth in name as well almost dreams so
people when we were watching this in the
in the office some people were really
freaked out by the imagery because yeah
30 of the it was more like pans why but
like this very guillermo del toro yeah
kind of dreamscapes I I love it like I
thought that looked really cool like I
really want to get a part to be a part
of this whereas I know Cygnus Randolph
Ramsey who's our managing editor and he
was like nope
this is not then that your fuel do I
hear it's real close to being super
creep I experienced this every night
already I don't know but I wake up in a
sweat and my guy gets too close and
spiders yeah I promise all of you it's
not fun but there I'm just kidding I'll
this looks interesting uh the that whole
like six axis or wherever I guys got
it's this right here I can that be
creepy look it's just a nice walking
over and then you again in the door cute
it's it's harry potter meets garum el
del toro needs mice night meets Mickey
Mouse look forward to playing nightmares
maybe next year I guess who we did this
no date on this yet so next year and
beyond as some bait is coming next year
battle born and there's no key beta
apparently coming to Sony's console
first and then we also got news of the
new GT game granturismo sport of which
there will be a beta next year as well
yeah what chick of that bad boy I'm
really like the Gran Turismo series I
didn't like six very much five was
pretty good but six just went too deep
into the like microtransaction thing for
yeah but you know I this is one series i
just i love also because what it like
represents which is this like this weird
like search for like high-tech and when
it comes out it's always just like oh
this is pretty great but it's not like
super futuristic but it's it's like a
silly little series though like it's got
this like horrible you i yes you know
like it takes itself way too seriously
but i really like the way it controls
traditionally and i like their their
particular attention to detail so i'm
looking forward to that and the fact
that's going to be in VR that's pretty
cool probably not the best way to play
it but probably a fun experience so do
you think that this game we'll come out
first or that we will put a manned
mission to Mars probably coincide on the
same day 15 if they're talking about it
like it is kind of a it's not really
peloponnese thing to say oh we're going
to have a you know betta within six
months of of this happening boy so I
mean what's going look I mean no
prologue this time yeah there's been a
lot of Gran Turismo games that fell
victim to delays but between five and
six wasn't that long you know how many
forts of games will come at listen I
would I'll bet haha at least three has
there been three since the loss Gran
Turismo yeah yeah
at least including a rose yeah and while
a lot of good games coming out next year
we have one sony game coming out this
year driveclub bikes I couldn't even get
out of my men that he started laughing
like that's their answer like Xbox has
been pushing like no we have a great
25th we're gonna talk about 2016 soon
but you got rise the tomb raider got
some halo what'swhat's PlayStation got
we're on bikes to that type anything you
like driveclub is just the middle-aged
man who's having like you know midlife
crisis thinks my motorcycles are gonna
solve everything throwing money at it
yeah it's currently available on the
PlayStation Store and I don't think this
is an expansion I think this is a yet is
a new standalone experience so you can
pay real world money for this literally
right now why are you watching this you
could be buying driveclub bikes I've no
idea what it costs finally padding to
try and see if I can see what the cost
is that's what I'm as soon as this is
finished I'm gonna go it's it's 15 euro
so it's probably fifteen dollars in that
case there you go go play it why aren't
you playing it yet are you playing it no
all right well if you're not playing
that lots of good sony playstation 4
games coming in in 2016 let us know what
you thought of as sony's and all the
games they showed off today boards
falling out of my mouth like David cage
we didn't talk about that actually it's
not coming out next year no all right
now you go hard anyway let us know what
you think of as Sony's 2016 lineup in
the comment box below